[Musique]
bienvenue paris-saclay tv ceux des
conflits nés vous emmène à la rencontre
de ceux et celles qui font vivre le
territoire
en ces temps de pandémie les commerces
de proximité ont besoin de notre soutien
certains se sont installés il ya peu de
temps comme le premier supermarché du
plateau de saclay mais il ya aussi le
clairon ou encore le living room et on
doit pas laisser lakovic 19 nous gâcher
nos fêtes nous allons faire le plein de
saveurs en allant à la même local c'est
une épicerie qui privilégie le circuit
court mais aussi connecté cette épicerie
vous le verrez le numérique est devenu
incontournable
est-ce que vous avez déjà pensé à des
réunions de bureau en réalité virtuelle
et bien ce qu'elle one portal l'a
inventé démonstration dans cette
émission
et puis avec ses confinement
déconfinement re confinement nous avons
besoin d'un grand bol d'air frais je
vous propose donc une jolie balade pour
découvrir la biodiversité du campus
[Musique]
vous les avez vu s'installer petit à
petit sur le territoire sur le plateau
de saclay les commerces de proximité
sont importants ils sont même
nécessaires pour les étudiants pour
leurs professeurs pour toutes les
personnes qui vivent qui travaillent ici
seulement voilà lakovic 19 est arrivé
les temps sont durs
nous sommes allés à la rencontre des
commerçants il témoigne bienvenue dans
le premier supermarché du plateau de
saclay donc notre supermarché franprix
qui a ouvert il ya un peu plus d'un an
donc au mois d'avril 2010 9
on a une clientèle donc je pense à 80%
étudiante et on a aussi une clientèle de
bureau avec toutes les entreprises qu'on
a autour de notre site
aujourd'hui sur deuxième confinement on
a pu rester ouverts avec avec notre
voisin boulanger on se sent un peu moins
seul on espère que l'ensemble du plateau
va se remplir
après après les fêtes de fin d'année et
retrouver un petit peu toute cette vie
sur le plateau qu'on apprécie tant
c'est d'abord une histoire de famille
clairement c'est comme ça que grand père
il appelait qu'on est également sur la
place du village et l'envoyer un coup de
clairon pour nous dire à table on a tous
types de clients
on arrive à être à iso périmètre à peu
près de services qu'avant de confinement
on a la chance d'aller ce qu'on est
mobile la nouvelle opportunité
le garder nos sites et de garder à peu
près le même type de service qu'avant
[Musique]
living room a été créée le 22 août l'an
dernier en 2019
c'est un restaurant dont traditionnelle
avec des fruits de mer des viandes des
poissons
on essaye vraiment de faire dans
palaiseau un restaurant chic agréable et
efficace sans pour autant aller sur
paris pour noël on a envie de se faire
plaisir malgré confinement et tous les
problèmes qu'on a je vais proposer des
plateaux de fruits de mer que vous
pourrez commander sur notre site
internet ou par téléphone jusqu'au 22
décembre des plateaux de fruits de mer
sur mesure donc faites travailler vos
commerces de proximité parce que
franchement on en a mais vraiment vous
en
ici on est à l'adagio access palaiseau
saclay c'est un hôtel qui a ouvert en
janvier 2019
cette année 2020 qui devait être
excellente vue le départ qu'on avait
chez en janvier février
malheureusement connu le coc vide alors
janvier on aimerait bien que tout
s'arrête et que tout reprenne ce que
nous on est prêts c'est une deuxième
année d'ouverture c'est dommage alors
que c'était prévu comme être une belle
année ont commencé à bien se faire
connaître en fin d'année les sociétés
aux alentours apprécié de d'envoyer
leurs collaborateurs chez nous il y
avait une vraie ambiance qui
malheureusement a été coupé avec le
confinement je suis installé ça fait un
peu plus d'un an ici avec mon épouse
donc on développe cette affaire dont
elle est un commerce d'utilité local
commerce de proximité
on est vraiment acteur local sur ce
plateau de saclay on est tombé sur une
période inédite dont sur l'ensemble du
territoire donc je suis pas le seul
mais c'est vrai qu'on est vraiment sur
une zone très tertiaire on a beaucoup de
sociétés autour de nous edf danone
thalès qui sont en télétravail edf à
100%
on a la chance d'avoir encore les
chantiers qui aujourd'hui représente
énormément de flux pour nous je pense
que ce sera une zone vraiment vraiment
très convoité il faut juste passer la
tempête comme on dit après le après la
tempête voilà le beau temps tout
simplement
[Musique]
en cette fin d'année il faut se faire
plaisir nous voici à l'amiable locale
une épicerie qui prône le circuit court
découvrez les produits de 60 producteurs
locaux pas d'intermédiaires ou presque
de la qualité avant tout on va laisser
le propriétaire des lieux vous
convaincre dans le même local est situé
sur le plateau du moulon le sourcing des
produits et le projet en soir ont débuté
en janvier 2020 et en neuf mois j'ai
monté le projet j'ai ouvert et
références et du coût 80 fournisseurs
nous avons accès de la communication
réellement sur les produits locaux et du
terroir
aujourd'hui on travaille avec un peu
plus de 80 fournisseurs présents
principalement d'eure-et-loir les
yvelines l'essonne paris la
seine-maritime ça regroupe un peu plus
de 500 produits 500 références
aujourd'hui le principe de la boutique
donc c'est des producteurs en circuit
court donc ses pieds des circuits courts
10 soit directement du producteur au
consommateur ou avec un seul intervenant
donc tous les producteurs présents sur
la boutique sont des personnes que j'ai
contacté directement que j'ai été voir
et on est réellement en circuit court
dieu de az sur sur tous les produits
j'ai été voir plus de 50 % des
producteurs directement alors leur
exploitation beaucoup sont des petits
producteurs qui sont en priorité avant
d'être commercial commerçants sont des
producteurs et artisans
on peut vous parler des produits vous
dire ah bah tiens intel à son usine qui
est neuf
intel a sa manière de fonctionner comme
ça parce qu'il ya un véritable échange
ale qui est des producteurs et artisans
les contraintes d'approvisionnement sont
du coup régulier est réglée par les
conditions climatiques par l'offre aussi
la demande qui assure sur le moment sur
certains produits
c'est réellement 500 plus de 500
produits qui sont disponibles et en
boutique et sur le site internet www.la
miam local point fr qui permet un drive
à partir de deux à quatre heures après
la commande pour venir récupérer
aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut nous souhaiter
c'est de développer la clientèle
je suis très présent sur les réseaux
sociaux que ce soit facebook instagram
linkedin sous le nom la mienne locale
n'a besoin que les gens nous connaissent
pas de nous entendre parler nous pour
pouvoir parler de nous et n'hésite pas à
venir nous rencontrer dans la boutique
[Musique]
le numérique c'est devenu incontournable
en ces temps de pandémie vous êtes
peut-être en télétravail mais ce que
vous avez pensé à des réunions en
réalité virtuelle
pascal one portal l'a inventé la tester
cette start-up planche sur d'autres
solutions innovantes
regardez ce qu'est le web portal fournit
des produits et des services axés autour
des usages des technologies immersives a
été augmentée ra été virtuel a été mixte
pour le compte de clients industriels
essentiellement pour les professionnels
on agit en réponse à des besoins très
spécifiques sur le demande de nos
clients
mais on a aussi des solutions sur
étagère qu'on déploie pour certains nos
clients à l'époque du premier
confinement s'est tous se retrouver un
peu du jour au lendemain chez nous il se
trouve qu'on avait une solution sur les
professionnels du divertissement et qui
permettait d'utiliser des cases heures
étaient virtuels léger autonome en
réseau donc en fait on a pris cette
technologie la cure la développer pour
en faire une espèce de salles de réunion
virtuelle
le principe de cette solution en fait
c'est que chaque utilisateur se
choisissait son avatar n'en sera en
trouvaient tous dans un bureau virtuel
et on a tenu comme ça des réunions un
petit peu bas déjà pour travailler un
peu l'actualité de la société comment on
s'organise parce qu'on a quand même été
obligé de ne pas mal réorienter nos
activités sa part mis pas mal de
phosphorer en fait sur tous ces sujets
en groupe et en retrouvant une
interaction assez naturel 1 ou ce qu'on
a constaté au moins notre niveau c'est
que les usages des technologies merci
pour de plus en plus personnalisés donc
on va avoir vraiment des solutions qui
vont permettre à base un simple
smartphone une paire de lunettes de
réalité augmentée de vraiment bénéficié
d'augmenter son environnement de
discuter avec des personnes qui sont pas
là c'est quelque chose qui va vraiment
se généraliser à priori dans les
prochaines années
ces technologies là aussi permettent de
dans le secteur de l'événementiel nom du
spectacle commencé à mettre en oeuvre
d'une forme de 10 finalisation des
prestations pouvoir les diffuser
j'irai dans des conditions semi réel
mais virtuel à des personnes qui n'ont
pas forcément accès à ce spectacle donc
évidemment on parle du confinement où
les gens sont restés chez eux mais on
parle aussi et ça c'est un désastre qui
on a travaillé avec le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pour les personnes qui n'ont pas accès
au théâtre on parle des personnes âgées
qui sont dans les ehpad
on parle des enfants malades notamment
c'est effectivement ce aussi un des axes
de travail sur lequel on peut avancer
pour utiliser ces technologies vers civ
dans une optique de mieux communiquer
avoir plus d'expérience sociale et
artistique
[Musique]
aller-retour dans la vraie vie pour une
jolie balade sur le campus de paris
saclay une balade pour découvrir la
biodiversité du site
gwénaël le quéré écologue nous dévoile
les secrets de cet écosystème
[Applaudissements]
bon
ce matin était organisé une balade sur
le thème de la biodiversité au coeur du
quartier l'école polytechnique certain
nombre d'aménagements étaient réalisés
en faveur de
l'accueil la circulation des espèces sur
ce quartier la prise en compte de la
biodiversité est intervenu très tôt dans
le dans la réflexion autour du
développement de ce quartier de façon à
préserver des circulations et des
espaces qu'ils soient favorables à la
biodiversité
ça veut dire
des espaces entre les fonctionnels qui
permettent d'accueillir un maximum
d'espèces les plus original possible
et puis ensuite de faire en sorte que ce
quartier soit perméable aux circulation
des espèces pour garantir l'accueil d'un
maximum d'espèces qui étaient parfois
présentes avant la création du quartier
qu'on souhaite maintenir
et puis l'accueil de nouvelles espèces
nouveaux cortèges d'espèces qui peuvent
se développer à la faveur des
aménagements qui sont réalisés comme les
aménagements de gestion des eaux
pluviales par exemple prennent beaucoup
de place d'un quartier mais qui sont
aussi des milieux des nouveaux
écosystèmes qui sont créés et donc
qu'ils sont favorables à l'accueil des
espèces spécifiques des oiseaux liés à
l'eau par exemple
sterne pierregarin qu'on peut retrouver
régulièrement sur ce secteur mais aussi
des petits limicoles comme le chevalier
guignette par exemple qui apprécient ce
genre d' espace donc à l'échelle du
quartier un certain nombre d'habitats
nouveaux ont été créés et qui
constituent des engagements de la part
de l'aménageur public qui sont là pour
être présent sur le long terme donc ils
sont entretenus dans un premier temps le
temps de la vie et du développement du
quartier par l'aménageur public
à terme c'est bien sûr des espaces qui
sont amenés à perdurer au delà
quand ce quartier sera achevée mais
qu'il vivra aussi avec ses populations
et donc des espaces qui sont amenés à
vivre sur le long terme
il ya des engagements de d'entretien
pendant une trentaine d'années mais bien
sûr elles ont vocation à durer bien plus
longtemps que ça avec une gestion par la
collectivité
et puis bien sûr l'appropriation par les
par les habitants de ces milieux leur
connaissance et la diffusion de leurs de
leur intérêt l'appropriation de ces
milieux par les populations et
et par la collectivité
[Musique]
notre agenda à présente si vous voulez
développer votre projet et si vous avez
encore des questions
rendez vous le 18 décembre une vision
conférence pour tous ceux et toutes
celles qui veulent se lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat se tient de 8h30 à 10h
pour s'inscrire à cet atelier il faut
contacter réjane point blanche et agglo
vgp point fr et si vous avez envie de
vous investir dans le développement
durable et bien participé aux privations
pour la planète
vous avez jusqu'au 17 janvier pour y
participer là toutes les informations
sont sur le site de la ville de jfl et
nous allons fêter en 2021
les dix ans du plateau avec par exemple
un paysage une exposition itinérante
consacrée aux plus grands projets
scientifiques économiques et urbains de
l'ouest parisien
et pour fêter cet anniversaire le pea
pas et saclay a demandé à trois
photographes trois plasticiens et il
renonça graphique d'exprimer leur vision
du projet son évolution
c'est à voir dès le 8 janvier à
versailles puis le hen s en février et
mars
et ça va continuer puisque c'est une
exposition itinérante
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission la
dernière de l'année je vous souhaite
d'excellentes fêtes de fin d'année
malgré lakovic 19
alors surtout surtout faites attention
faites attention à vous et à vos proches
de passer de très belles fêtes je
retrouve l'année prochaine
[Musique]